depuis une semaine on en parle partout
les trois personnes vont très bien et
chaque jour on en apprend un peu plus le
nouveau coronavirus est il vraiment
dangereux
ce qu'on sait pas encore c'est
exactement à quel point ce virus-là et
virulent c'est à dire que on est on a de
la mortalité
mais est-ce qu'elle est aussi élevé qu'à
l'époque ce sera soit on était plus
autour de 10 14%
présentement n'est plus autour de 2 3%
pour le moment une grande partie des
morts étaient des patients vulnérables
âgées de 65 ans et plus mais on ignore
toujours le nombre exact de personnes
infectées
comment le virus se transmet t-il
l'exploitation des cas à travers le mans
le nombre est faible et finalement la
transmission de ce virus exige une
contact étroit pour l'instant c'est par
gouttelettes sont à fait bouclé et par
contact donc la même façon que le ver
est justement les symptômes de ce
nouveau virus s'apparentent à ceux d'un
rhume notamment de la fièvre mais qui
entraîne des problèmes plus graves comme
des difficultés respiratoires ou des
pneumonies
or l'élément déterminant reste encore
l'historique de voyage puisque le foyer
de l'épidémie se trouve dans la province
de hub et en chine
alors si on n'a pas voyagé le risque que
ce soit m kobe c'est comme zéro parce
qu'il n'y a pas encore de transmission
ici mais une personnes infectées
pourraient être contagieuses jusqu'à
deux semaines avant l'apparition des
symptômes
c'est ce que les autorités chinoises
croient la capacité du virus à se
répandre semble devenir plus forte
difficile donc de prévoir exactement
comment l'épidémie évoluera d'où
l'importance des mesures sanitaires en
place ici jacques houde rue charbonneau
radio-canada mourir